John McCain almost lost his bid to
become the Republican nominee in 2007
based on the fact that he had for a long
time support comprehensive immigration
reform or as it was known back then as
McCain Kennedy in two thousand six and
two thousand seven when he was preparing
his run for presidency he tried to
offload the heavy lifting of
comprehensive immigration reform to his
colleague in the Senate from Arizona jon
kyl who had just won reelection on a
largely anti-immigration campaign
something that people in arizona noticed
but not many people outside of arizona
for mccain is a very interesting issue
part of it stems from his kind of elite
idea that he thinks that the grass root
of his own Republican Party tend to be
kind of knuckle draggers 10 to flirt
with racism and xenophobia that he finds
personally abhorrent one of his best
friends the Naval Academy whose guy
named Frank gambella was a
mexican-american who became referred to
as the mex and ever since then he has
always spoken very movingly about all
these sort of Spanish surnames that he
finds in the Vietnam War Memorial he has
an allergy to racism that I think is is
heartening on the other hand like all of
McCain's reforms his ideas about what to
do about immigration to make a grand
compromise end up having deleterious
effects on individual liberty largely
because his schemes would basically end
up forcing people to use the e-verify
program it would force a very a
technocratic and bureaucratic way for
employers to line up with immigrants
coming from abroad and by the end the
bill that got killed was not something
that people who are in favor of a
streamlined immigration process I think
could really support but what you will
find is that since he has now come out
against his own bill and even little
parts of it including the DREAM Act
which would have given college tuition
to illegal immigrants in-state tuition
McCain is distancing himself from that
low point of his candidacy and you won't
hear him talk certainly this week
about immigration which you will hear on
the Democratic side is that if there's a
single person running for president this
time around who has the greatest chance
to do something about immigration once
he's elected it's not Barack Obama it's
John McCain